is it trashy if your dad took you to the
prison he works at to get a free haircut
[Applause]
that looks great thanks so much take
care guys now who would cut the hair
would it be an inmate or would it be uh
like a barber that they hired
an inmate
It's gotta be a lead that's crazy
I'm sure you skipped a lollipop too on
the way out the door I think some good
Dan get your tickets for all the cities
on the state trashy tour and are you
garbage.com welcome so another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're going to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave trolley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at hoodies in the new edition she
just started a new little business for
herself okay stealing catalytic
converters shout out to her yeah my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me slightly unamused this week he is
the CEO of Ru garbage and he's my best
pal in the whole wide world and I love
them give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are true to rev cooking
and then the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com gang it's a [__]
party over there check it out yes sir
and having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes and
he's no stranger to an ollie I can tell
you that give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody
Applause
there you go oh my you were clapping at
me like a dad proudest kid just hit a
home run man
I'm excited we got a great guy in the
audition I've been hearing about him for
years I'm still yeah getting the long
hair ain't lying we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he is a very
funny stand-up comedian and actor and
you might have seen him in but not
limited to Here We Go Gang we got happy
family Cedric the Entertainer presents
train wreck Inside Amy Schumer 12
episodes of that also produced on that
show and wrote 39 episodes then he got
16 episodes of Reno 9-1-1 he got a
Mortal Compass he got Crank Yankers
Garfunkel and Oates he's got his own
Comedy Central presents the Jim Brewer
show Conan Jimmy Kimmel Craig Ferguson
how we do it your mom's house Seth
Meyers tigerbelly WTF the Howard Stern
Show lights out with David Spade the Joe
Rogan Experience he has his own YouTube
page that's got about 400 000
subscribers and you can watch the fresh
press of DC and the Kyle Dunnigan show
over there and he's on tour right now
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
one the only Kyle Dunnigan
I've never had someone get that many
credits kill an intro yeah
happy family I was fired from and I
still got paid never made the air well
you know what I have like a I can't read
well
I might Jam you up in the acting Biz
wait why can't you read well you know
things are backwards and I just I read
like a I have to go back and forth like
I I guess words and I get to the end of
the sentence I go that wasn't that
wasn't believe that was the difference
and then I go back what was that it
takes me forever so I just don't really
read okay and then you know when you
audition I'd have to memorize everything
in order to audition sure so I there was
like five callbacks it was a lot to get
this part it was like a recurring role
in this NBC show and then I got it and
then I go to the table read and they do
the network comes you know they call it
a network tip reading so it's high
pressure and everyone the writers are
everyone's laughing at their own jokes
and everything and it's usually you kill
usually but they go like five minutes we
got eight new lines for you
we have some new lines and I was like in
my head I was like I'm fired oh no and I
should have said I I should have said
listen I can't read I don't know how to
read
and it's a discrimination but I had that
just hopeful like maybe I'll do it this
time sure so they come everyone's just
killing everyone's laughing and then
they get to my line and I swear it was
just like we should we should get to the
Sky style or we should get to the store
before
night night midnight it's like dead
science next person laugh laugh laugh
comes back to me I'm like
[Laughter]
and then the next I didn't hear anything
I went back the next day and I get to
the studio and the castner was like arms
like really no
and then she goes um yeah they're gonna
like get somebody else but
um you get you're going to a rack
tomorrow right I was going to a rack the
next day okay like that was a you get to
go like she's like yeah
how do you feel about war zones Kyle and
then we've got those IEDs huh yeah we
went to Iraq and it was like a six day
thing and then our hotel got motor
attacked Jesus
send them to Iraq and Obama
anyway thanks for saying the credit
what is the backstory of Kyle Dunnigan
give us give us the full scoop where'd
you grow up give us a story what a
disaster I grew up in Western
Connecticut which is a Connecticut okay
Town yes Westport is like the town you'd
go to Weston's Like Houses so we grew up
in the west and outskirts in The
Boondocks and uh you know nice family
um older brother and sister uh parents
stayed together till God killed my dad
with a brain tumor okay okay
not the nicest thing I thought we had a
good thing going here and so
um what did they do what'd your mom and
dad do for a living my father was a
lawyer okay because I was gonna say
we've seen the house
on the gram right yeah it is
church yeah my mom's in a nice actually
that's her home you shoot and we're not
doing research yeah you shoot a bunch of
sketches in the house
right we're not driving around with the
star Maps out in Western Connecticut all
of your biggest sketches were shot in
the house
we know where Craig lives
they're in vibrants and viral videos
yeah you haven't noticed the flower
truck parked outside for the last five
months
I when I got here you guys said this is
a safe sign I swear they said that I was
like okay thank you and it's like abuse
don't spin this on us all right anyway
so yeah my mom actually grew up on that
property and knocked her childhood home
down okay and then built this Mansion
but here's the story because my dad was
an airplane lawyer really what is that
he focused on airplane crashes hit a
specialty no he was a pilot he had like
a tiny little plane we almost died in
five times
well we're fine it's like what everyone
dies on sure so um he had got this huge
case now he before this he never made a
lot of money and he had this law firm
and they just were sucking from he was a
very hard worker but he would go on
vacation for a month and the law firm
would lose money so he just was always
frustrated so then this big airplane
crash happened
um Ron Brown it was like a Croatian
yeah whenever the plane crash was like
so
um a bunch of multi-millionaires on the
plane the way it works is if and an
airliner or it was a private plane it
was a kind of a famous crash because Ron
Brown was on it he was like the
Secretary of Treasury or something and
it was just like eight multi-millionaire
I mean there's more than that rich
people and so if a plane if they find
out it's someone's fault then there's
someone to Sue and it was like the maps
were out of date my dad found out the
maps were on a date there was like a
reason why they crashed it was someone's
fault so then what happens is you go and
you go okay how much would this person
have made if they survived because they
should have survived they should have
died so then the first wife got 19
million dollars and then the lawyer gets
a third of that but my dad got the brain
tumor like way early and so he had to
split the first thing so it was like
five million so we got like 2.5 million
damn no but he was like they were kind
of in debt and like my mom never worked
a day in her life is this before the
House was built yeah this is they're in
Weston and he's kind of in debt but he's
never made money but are you alive for
this I I was alive you were born okay
yes this is he died in like I was like
27 or something so um he got that money
from my mom so she wouldn't have to work
again but it was not like if he just
lived another year he would have made
like 60 million dollars
and the rest just settled like like that
but he got sick and um he wasn't able to
do it but he got that little bit and so
my mom's like set up but she's not like
crazy Rich gotcha uh she's fine does the
law firm still exist he when he got that
case he left that law firm and started
his own and then they sued him and they
took his car Jesus and then still got
the plane yeah well no there was that
cologne by like Twitter people and then
it's like a spider web up there yeah
catch a break yeah yeah so anyway I'm
not sure what the point of my story he
oh and when 9 11 happened like they were
trying to get down
get in the car no he had died before
that but they they were looking for him
like because he was like the plane crash
guy you know what I mean wait is Mr
Dunagan s quiet so he would have I mean
my dad would have made a lot of money
it's not about the money guys
sure it's about the love for law sure
that's how all lawyers get in they love
arguing
I was down in ground zero oh wait this
might be a garbage thing I did okay
well would you rob a bank on 911 what do
you mean a little worse than that I wish
I robbed it back so I had this Pizza Hut
campaign you know when they go you have
a campaign of commercials you've just
won the lottery sure Progressive ladies
yeah seeing these things happen Okay so
I go to this audition and I somehow got
the new Pizza Hut guy as Kyle done again
okay and I'm broke and I'm in California
I'm like well let's just go uh Mansion
shopping shall we and so I do the first
four and it's like millions of dollars
they're spending on these okay we shut
down Rodeo Drive and the director's like
you're gonna make so much goddamn what's
the action if you don't mind because I
know that they're very lucrative but
what's the actual like what'd you get
paid for that they don't pay you up
front if we did another cycle of them
that probably would have done a deal
with me and giving you like a couple
million dollars whatever okay for the
next but like this was just like okay
you get paid per viewing of the things
so we shot for them one of them we shot
on 911 and we're like do we still shoot
today and I'm like I think they would
have wanted us to shoot
if we don't shoot this thing
yeah no [__] so we shoot these and the
thing was it was that the big New York
of pizza
places a kaboom it's just they'll knock
your buildings down it was it wasn't the
right tone so they canceled it like they
aired a few and they were like
and this is like we shot four two
dressed up like a terrorist yeah
and uh we shall have four in there like
there's gonna be more and and
um and there were none they're they just
dried up and then I was on nine I was at
Ground Zero it was still smoking when I
got the call that they were just
canceling the whole thing what were you
doing down there
let's see I was having a good time just
you know
having a good time I just wanted to
spend some of that Pizza Hut money well
that was there was a lot of I don't
remember but during at 9 11 there's a
lot of talk about 9 11. yeah sure like
around the time sure I remember so I was
in New York I'm like let me go down to
Ground Zero gotcha it's the Talk of the
Town gotcha yeah if I could go to that
submarine area
so I'm down there and they're like yeah
it's all canceled you're broke again and
I was like I'm like God damn it I'm like
[__] [__] and people probably thought
my family died there's smoking behind me
and I'm like why why God why me uh it
was a tone deaf sure that's all but I
was younger and I would never do that
now sure I would totally
um do it in the privacy of your own home
sure the Privacy uh anyway that was a
thing a garbage thing did you ever get
any of the cash
I made I think like 30 that 40 000. that
ain't bad it's so bad 2001 money so bad
it's so bad when they're like you're
gonna make millions of dollars sure and
you get 30 000 the government takes half
you know fifteen thousand sure man you
have those weekends like 5 000 on
cocaine one weekend sure now you got ten
left yeah I've never done two more
weekends I've never done cocaine and I'm
not even against it just never came up
in my face really really I don't know
what La actor comedian I can't get a
read on this guy I didn't have cool
friends huh if it was in my face I would
have tried it because I actually I'm
probably too old now I probably would
die so I probably shouldn't do it now
but like yeah this isn't a good time for
cocaine it's got some bad PR is it bad
time for cocaine right now it's not good
I don't think it's laced with fentanyl
used to be so good remember when it was
a good old days yeah the talk of cocaine
uh uh uh down below uh good time to but
to do cocaine just
it's a good time to buy
um go bats go back to uh Weston what was
the grocery store that you went to as a
kid ugh it was not even
you know there's like Deli these little
grocery stores in uh New York on the
streets sure that it was like that much
selection it was like a market it was
like a market you'd have to go to
Westport to do everything because the
movies have fun Weston was just like a I
don't know a house town that makes sense
but it was very um safe and um I guess a
nice place to grow up okay well it was a
family whip where you drive what was
your dad driving around then your mom's
driving around uh
my mom had like a Toyota Camry for a
while okay my dad had a
um excuse me
he liked Audis okay all right nice car
nice car and then the the law firm when
he was like hey guys I'm making all the
money and like what the [__] they were
here's a car I left them Alexis for like
but then they took that away sure so he
didn't really have that did they get any
money as when they sued him or did he
win the case you know what which was
kind of cool then they did when you got
a brain Turner they dropped it Ah that's
nice they were like all right we're not
he got it hard enough freaking [__]
yeah but I mean they should never have
sued him I mean the guy
you know started this whole thing where
they have they're making all their money
and they just didn't and um you know
anyway but hey what uh what were the
family vacations like growing up uh nice
we would go to every winter we would go
to the Caribbean which sounds very nice
yeah but um whole family you and your
older family okay uh Puerto Plata nice
[Music]
that's not a safe place but we didn't
know until we got there they were like
oh this is um war-torn
but anyway yeah nice vacations fam my my
parents stayed together no divorce there
uh my dad was pretty quiet it was a
smart guy but he was like kind of
pensive and then the women in the house
were like
I love them but like they were the
dominant things they ran it they ran
that house and we would the men would
just hide away what's the pet situation
growing up and he lives
yeah I like my poodle I got a I got a
pug chihuahua now which is more fun okay
Pluto was my dog now was nice and dumb
and I like it was funnier it's a funnier
dumb dogs are all right multiple poodles
growing up or just one poodle at a time
one one that's it that's it how long did
it last uh like uh 15 years okay I got
it when it's 11. it lasted my whole way
through high school and everything like
that okay are you gathering information
you're starting to paint the picture we
are okay we're getting there what uh
what kind of student were you good
so I did terribly I did well in like
other stuff though other topics like I
was I I did like physics I was advanced
in physics I was with like the older
kids interesting yeah you're gonna say
kickball or something like that I wasn't
bad were you at did play did you play
sports athletic at all or no uh yeah it
was okay I played golf which um is a
real panty dropper in high school but we
had a
and my freshman I only did my freshman
year I was I was fifth Varsity so I was
like one there's like one person for
each number or whatever okay five people
on the Farsi team and I was fifth
Varsity then there was a party in the
top four Varsity guys got suspended so I
was number one there you go
as a freshman freshman I lost every I
lost every game the whole year called
the cops on that party didn't you
dropping dime
that's my shot you over to the
sloshburg's house right now you'll catch
them all hey
um any family pics together wearing the
same clothes no on the beach everyone
wearing white mom wanted to do that but
sure okay it's a good question that is
okay well I'm putting it together the
the the Caribbean winter vacations the
Audi the law firm the small plane I
could see that happening we didn't feel
rich because our town like my friends
were more Rich my friends were okay like
pools and they had more money so were a
lot of the houses in your neighborhood
knockdowns and then rebuilt we were in
the poor area they were not big houses
no they weren't rebuilt but then when
yours was were you guys the hottest
house in in the neighborhood Westport
you're seeing that my mother moved to
West my father died
okay I was in L.A gotcha Hollywood
gotcha not doing coke yeah sure
everything
okay let's talk about indochino oh baby
Fresh Threads talk about not looking
like a bozo say you got a wedding coming
up you got the high school reunion you
want to look good and you can look good
with Indochina we're talking suits and
shirts and Casual Wear custom fitted
comes with a surprisingly affordable
price tag as well yeah uh let them
straighten you out well I know I dress
like a bozo for a long time I still do
but you got to go to somewhere to
stretch out indochino is here to take
care of you create a suit that fits you
and your style perfectly you can choose
everything about it the fabric the lapel
statement Linings which I'm big on as
you know you can even class it up a bit
and add a monogram it's fantastic I got
one I got a monogram it says Kippy on
the inside shout out to you indochino
suit start uh from just 579 in shirts
for 89 with all the customations
included for for more chill lead days
check out their casual shirts man work
through that well well it's for more
chill days I I I got my own I had my own
Artistic Touch and said chili days check
out that's for when you eat jelly check
out their casual shirts and camp shirts
you'll be looking great in no time no
matter what you're up to so RSVP knowing
you got the perfect look at all wedding
season long fro from indochino go to
indochino.com and use the code garbage
to get 10 off any purchase of 399 or
more that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code garbage
do it okay let's talk about fumes shout
out to fume baby gang where you're
trying to get up the sauce or you're
trying to stop spending all of the money
in your retirement fun quitting
something can be tough as we all know if
you're looking to quit that nasty
hand-to-mouth habit you're not alone and
I'll tell you this right now fume can
help it's a cool Innovative design
device device that takes the bad out of
the bad habit fume replaces Electronics
vapor and harmful chemicals with all
natural flavored air yeah it's awesome
the fume's been a big supporter of the
show years ago the jump they've been
sending us the stuff it's easy peasy you
take the little filter you pop it in
it's a little flavor whatever you need
you you poop your little tutor rootsky
it's fantastic uh if your fidgety fume
has movable parts and magnets to keep
your hands occupied which is a big thing
the tangible
and with adjustable airflow awesome
flavors to choose from you can totally
customize your experience stopping is
something we're all we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 100
000 customers it has thousands of
success stories there's no reason you
can't be that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanities break up from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to trifum.com
use the code garbage to save 10 when you
get the journey pack today that's
trifum.com use code garbage to save an
additional 10 of your order today
tryfume.com code garbage do it I'm back
to the gosh darn show do it today
um and that was Tiny that was a tiny boy
okay and uh it was upsetting because I
you know you like girls and then you you
see where you are in the social
um structure and the the popular girls
were like we decided you're going to be
Class Clown like they decided what the
superlative was and then I got upset
because you see like oh you're a clown
and then I I cried and then they found
out he was the hot kid the whole time
started crying I did I thought I was
no 12. come on guys I'm shooting 15
overpower over here I knew I wasn't hot
at 12. for sure hold on you started
crying where yeah well that's my friend
I got upset it was a bunch of things I
played this like I don't even talk about
but I'm a little Albert in like the dumb
Mary Poppins play and I just was like
this clown and then this girl I liked
was like you make the perfect Uncle
Albert who's like an oh stupid man and
clown and then they were like that clown
and then I was like upset about it and
then I guess my friend told like the
administrator they whatever faculty and
they'd change it to best personality
there you go
what about your bedroom what was uh what
was it oh my God this is like a great
transition because I don't know what we
need a psychologist in there but my
mother for somehow she finally found out
like I was upset about the clown thing
and I was put a Class Clown she filled
my room with clowns holy [__] what the
[__] has her [__] up my phone when it
rang we go that's hysterical and I'd be
like hello maybe a big clown I hate a
clown and that was a picture of a clown
with a hat that said I love girls on it
it's like in my room and I'm like I
hated my room she's just crazy you
couldn't take that stuff down I here's
what what's like this is your senior
Year we're talking yeah I still deal
with this I have trouble knowing what I
want and what I like because I'm not
sure so I if you don't want to be here
you can leave I wouldn't know I might
want to leave I don't know but I just
was kind of told what to do okay so
heavily since uh one years old that I
was just told what I liked and then I
just things would happen like I didn't
know I love music but I didn't it didn't
dawn it that I could go buy music I
liked and listen to it all right never
bought like a CD or or anything I just
sort of would try to find the song on
the radio because my I I just was so not
anything I kind of wanted
like when I was younger you guys are so
worried about me but I had a great child
that they should be called are you okay
I I I'm I've gone to therapy
everything's fine I'm learning to know
what I want but I do have I to struggle
and I sort of go with whatever the flow
is he didn't do Columbia House when you
were a kid and get the CDs for a penny
or anything like that neb no no what did
your mom listen to what was that was her
favorite I mean this is back when you
couldn't yell at Alexa to play something
sure there's a whole process but they
were my parents listen to like ABBA all
right okay I'm with you which I enjoyed
sure
um Engelbert Humperdinck sure was a
favorite okay all right
um anyway great I had a great mom and a
great dad I just this thing also it's
like whatever happened in my childhood I
somehow uh had trouble
um saying I don't like that or I like
that for whatever reason my mom's fault
but like I had trouble picky eater is a
kid
uh uh not too much now no not too bad
would they pack your lunch or would you
buy a lunch at school Act made lunch
with a smiley face and a like a carrot
and like some some potato chips in a bag
okay a sandwich with Wonder Bread which
is good for you sure
sometimes you'll be I got peanut butter
and fluff nice
just a cook that's a good yeah piece of
cake yeah dessert yeah but um yeah I
don't know how maybe that maybe that's
why I was Tiny I was I was just having
malnourished yeah I would do when I
would start to play golf when I was
young I only played like two years I
burnt out but I get kind of obsessed
with things it's hard being on tour okay
well it's hard when you go to the the
Your Country Club sometimes you have to
carry your own apart do your parents
you guys are a member of the country
club uh yeah but it was really my mom
only for a couple years I was really
obsessed with golf I was the one who
went there but I would go there and I
would play I would walk 18 holes get a
Snickers bar and a Sprite and then walk
another 18 holes and then put till it
was dark and I would just do that over
and over damn like yeah I had a kind of
psycho behavior when I was younger I'm
not like that anymore but I would fly a
kite till I peed in my pants
I just wait what I met with my tongue on
his back it was before they diagnosed
just a long time ago they didn't say
like there's so much wrong with them
they're just like [__] like he can't
read Kyle you can't go to the bathroom
if you won yeah yeah I just like peed my
pants and couldn't read and but
everything's fine now
you should be happy with that class
clown [__] title from
Peter Pan did you have a lot of hands
cut kid did you have a lot of friends
growing up uh yeah but they were
invisible no I did I
I I had a decent amount okay okay what
was your first concert that you went to
Oh Billy Joel really how old was that
Billy Joel ooh probably like seven
sixteen okay in high school did you go
with your parents did you go by yourself
no I went I went with friends and then I
went again I have a whole Billy Joel
thing I'll try to talk real quick
because I love Billy Joel I was in
college this girl was like hey I have an
extra ticket to Billy Joel ninth row and
I was like yes because I imagined very
clearly I'm gonna jump on stage I'm
gonna Rush the stage I'm in the ninth
row you know this guy's a loose cannon I
love you Billy he gets tased
oh
Wendy hears it okay so so then she takes
a ticket away from me but I'd already
imagined I'd already the secreted it
which I don't really believe in but I
also do believe in it because in my life
when I've really imagined something like
it seems like it kind of happens so I go
to the concert the same tour but now I
had to buy my own tickets I'm at Yankee
Stadium second to last row you could
touch the backing the delay from Billy's
singing it was insane it was like he's
seeing Uptown Girl we're hearing Piano
Man why is going on so I'm all mad cause
I had ninth throw seats why'd she take
the ticket away her friend wanted to go
did you mention she wasn't gonna Rush
this yeah did you mention any of your
Manifesto plans to her I know okay like
that it was just she was just like I
found something someone better than you
was the thing so I go to my nine friends
I go let's run let's go let's sneak down
to the thing and try to rush the states
no one had rushed yet
so we all went down they all got caught
immediately like there's guards right
there ticket flashlight every 15 feet
you know and the ticket says tear on it
in big letters and I'm just going and
they keep pointing me next Dan He
pointed me where I want to go crazy I
went by like six different card stands
yeah I go all and I'm in the front I go
right to the stage I go right to the
stage and then everyone rushes so now
I'm like front and center Billy Joel
right there and then here you go
and I gotta say that this is an
important part of of the story I
was sure I have I had AIDS no okay it
wasn't like I might have AIDS I was like
I'm dying of AIDS now why would I think
that I had sex with one girl one time
and but back then sure unprotected sex
it you had AIDS
it was cover of Time Magazine just like
it just said Aids on every magazine
thing and this girl was had sex with me
which no one ever does so she was must
have been loosey-goosey and she was 21
which is so much older than me how old
were you at this time 16 what about his
first year in college like yeah I was
like 17 18. yeah 18. so now and I've
lived with AIDS for like a year at this
point you know because it's been no
medicine too that's a pretty good that's
pretty good I could I try to get test it
but again with my personality I don't
have an initiative I went to the I
called the school nurse and they're like
we don't do that called the school nurse
can you test me for AIDS yeah and she
goes we don't do that and I was like
okay I guess I'll just live with AIDS
so I'm at this concert front row and I'm
like I'm gonna jump on stage like I
imagined you know and the concert's
ending and then uh I gotten too scared
you know there's big guards and stuff
and I looked on this lady and I go hey
you want to jump the stage with me I
think she'd get tackled first I'd
probably faster
Housewife of Long Island and push her
into the guy and she's going to be my
fullback she goes I'm a scary mary had
never heard that before LOL that's
what's sticking into your head from this
wouldn't it stick in your head like what
a weird thing she said to me it was
[__] crazy I'm a scary Mary just
because it Rhymes your name's Mary now
anyway I listen lady I don't know what
the [__] that means I Gotta Give Billy
Joel AIDS yeah
how much time I have left I gotta move
now I don't have time for your little
quips fake names
so Billy Joel's walking out time is
ticking toots let's go Billy Joel starts
walking out right and uh I go I'm too
scared you know and then I remember
I have AIDS
I'm dying anyway so the power of AIDS
literally propelled me onto the stage
okay okay and I jumped up I Pat him a
bag said good job he's like hey thanks
and then a guard came up and barreled
his shoulder and then I was behind Billy
Joel like this you know the guard and
I'm like don't touch me I have AIDS and
then they just let me down gently but I
it was all filmed and I have it on film
and then it was they were filming a
Billy Joel live at Yankee Stadium oh
yeah I've seen that yeah I'm in that I'm
thinking wait no wait I haven't seen the
whole thing I'm at the very are you
credited
I was gonna ask is at the concert where
they do uh they do the live version of
uh the Miami yeah 51 oh yeah yeah you
were that that show yeah yeah God damn
at the show
I was the star of that show I had I have
it here I'll show you guys okay so now
cut to this is way longer than You're
Expecting but cut to 25 years later
almost to the day
I got eight
I was invited to
um you know the the movie train wreck
sure yes okay so I've been writing for
Amy and she had put Billy Joel music in
that
um movie okay because you you know
you're like Billy Joel music whatever so
she was like Hey I'm gonna dance on
stage with Billy Joel me and um Jennifer
Lawrence come to Chicago and and just
come on stage you could meet him and I
was like so psyched
so 25 years later I go and it's the same
type of thing where it was a stadium and
it was it first went to his rehearsal
and like I went up and onto the stage at
the same way and he's the same play it
was so weird
it was crazy and then I showed him the
video of me jumping on stage and I had
that too on film him his reaction
security no I know but he had to be nice
to me because like Jennifer Lawrence was
there
yeah I have like all this on film isn't
it not a weird way how did you find it
you then watched the Billy Joel live at
Yankee Stadium in Seoul yourself is that
how you have it yeah and they have like
three different angles like they put it
in they were like oh this is like the
psycho's jumping on dude that's [__]
insane isn't that crazy did they put you
in baseball stadium jail
yeah you gotta go and they put the Hat
on your head should I put them in a
straight jacket yeah this is like
getting yeah yeah this is like from the
days
then this would be showing this is me as
an 18 year old jumping on Space he is
running on stage yeah
yeah the whole thing anyway listen you
have no idea he looks really confused to
talk to you you just asked me did I go
to a concert ever in that 40 minutes
later I'm like I have AIDS I scare Billy
Joel
I tried to kidnap Billy Joel oh my gosh
anyway I [__] love Billy Joel's
appointment just saw him at the Garden
fantastic uh any carpet in the bathroom
or the kitchen at your original house oh
God we're gonna we're gonna get this is
gonna this sounds [__] crazy but
we're already there buddy
I mean
this doesn't be accosting Billy Joel
with AIDS is a this is weird but is
there an option to not put this out
you do this all the time you can throw
one out right you're not gonna it's
gonna hurt you guys this only hurts me
we we got our whole house recarpeted
okay every room is recovered except for
my room
why
clowns old carpet look I don't know look
we did some therapy
I don't know I'd like to keep I was like
the youngest like to make sure I didn't
like I don't know feel too good pee on
the floor or something like that yeah
yeah but anyway yeah we had carpet No
carpet in the kitchen you asked yeah no
no in the bathroom no
um were you close with your grandparents
growing up yeah my grandparents one one
side was closer to the other but my
grandmother my father's side was a she
was a little Sterly were they all up
there in the same area my mother's
Grandparents were close they were in the
house or the proper that my mom's on now
in Westport where'd your dad Grow Up by
the way we're up in Woburn Massachusetts
and he actually fell into that pond that
they dumped they'd put them did a movie
they dumped all the toxic waste in that
pond it was called a civil action with
John Travolta okay and my dad fell into
that pond because he was ice skating it
didn't freeze it was like mostly
chemicals and then he did get a brain
tumor jeez it might have been something
like that
yeah it's in the Navy yeah okay yeah he
was he grew up very poor and he didn't
do well in school but they uh had this
program at bu if you like to talk like
this like IQ test whatever for the kids
that were
dropped out or whatever you could get
into like some program there and he saw
there was a house he was like it was a
big house and he was like what do they
do and someone's like that's a lawyer
he's like okay I'll do that oh wow
anyway he loved to read ironically he
read even on vacation he was reading and
I didn't understand
none of us really the whole family was
not very smart except for him and so he
didn't really relate to anybody he was
like who's this guy uh where did you go
to college
I went to Harvard uh
I'm like what the [__] I think he can't
read I went to Ithaca then I went to
UConn okay yeah there you go full
basketball
women's
walked on the golf team oh yeah had them
all arrested I was number one I was
gonna ask what did you call your
grandparents what were their nicknames
Nanny and Gramps Nanny and Gramps that's
all right that's not bad that's kitchen
and then Nana and Grandpa were the other
side okay okay but my grandma she was uh
on my dad's side she was kind of like
she was always smoking and she was like
my lungs are clear as a bell but you
didn't hear they weren't and they were
driving back from some place and she's
smoking it's coming into the back seat
I'm getting I'm about to barf and I
didn't I was kind of a shy kid it was
very difficult for me to say this but I
said Danny can you please stop smoking I
think I'm gonna get sick and she goes
bad guys rather just smoking yeah
that just kept smoking you know sure and
then we opened that and then we got out
of the car I remember KFC and I just
looked down in my flip-flops and I just
barfed right between my flip-flops
and she wasn't like I'm so sorry to tell
me that she was like God yeah
it's gonna be shoes before you get back
in the car I think she had a tough life
you know what I mean all right lady sure
sure yeah judge a you can't judge a
person is what I it's a different
generation they didn't know any better
okay next question next question what
was the uh magnet situation on the
fridge growing up was it an abundance of
magnets by any chance no there were not
okay I'm interested to know why like how
these are garbage these are garbage
people that would have that yeah yeah
the Kennedys don't have a bunch of you
know magnets from New Mexico or whatever
what about Christmas what'd you guys do
at Christmas
we used to say the aliens that get those
off are [__] Bridge no it's a
question going to buy Christmas you guys
celebrate Christmas loved it was huge
white lights colored lights what would
you do
um poof I think we colored lights
on the outside of the house too no no
we're a big decoration outside I'm
talking about the tree yeah okay I think
a white Christmas tree lights class
white class yeah White's classy I don't
think I think it's soulless you're crazy
am I crazy you're feeding your pants
that was the only time I was like 12. I
don't do that anymore
would you use tinsel on the tree you
remember no how about the popcorn things
no no no we ain't like that okay
Connecticut still have a little bit of
clay Christmas in Connecticut they make
movies about this stuff
they just made it so nice
um they actually tore down this they had
a bridge okay and it was this old
rickety uh bridge and they tore down and
built a nice bridge and then Martha
Stewart was like this has no charm and
the town ripped down the brand new
multi-million dollar bridge and put up
the rickety City
anyway it is a nice Bridge it has
colored lights on it year round no [__]
yeah [__] a lot of [__]
uh you call it mini golf or Putt-Putt
mini golf okay gentlemen that's the
classier answer grocery uh Pharmacy or
drugstore
Pharmacy not bad call it ground beef or
hamburger pulled out of this
you still got a chance
you are in a class all by yourself
that's not right now uh what was the
question hamburger meat or ground beef
ground beef okay
all right have you ever been inside a PT
Cruiser oh I think I'm gonna say a woman
that's how you're gonna hate both no no
both yes PT Cruiser yeah wait a minute
is that the Jeep thing yeah it's like uh
Chrysler made him yeah no I don't think
so I don't think so you would not you
would know if you were inside a BPT
Cruiser that's not something you forget
about let's talk about new debt let's
talk about now uh you'd mentioned before
you own a home in Los Angeles selling it
you're selling it right now yes how long
have you owned that home seven years
seven years okay was there seven
wonderful years was there a big influx
of cash when you bought that home was
something cooking no I just always been
kind of a saver okay I never really had
big hits you know a lot of like Pizza
Hut like get ready for the roller
coasters that never happened but I did
save and I invest in the stock market I
like stock market really yeah I do
actually I like every day I study like
that kind of stuff no kids any big
scores off that or just kind of yeah I
put a lot of Tesla like very early oh
[__] yeah all right yeah any crypto I
did have crypto but I got out of it when
it started to like look like uh not
great scam I still have like a like 5
000 in crypto in Bitcoin or something
like that okay I don't know how to get
it yeah
it isn't a wallet but it's like they're
cracking down I don't know how to I'm
just gonna leave it see what happens
yeah okay yeah yes all right so you got
the house in La uh
where are you at right now
well I'm the studio uh well I'm renting
on in Manhattan and I love okay and I
walked to the cellar I walk to the stand
east side or west side if you don't mind
me asking just well
east side and I just walked to the
cellar in the stand I know it's gonna
get cold and it's gonna be impossible
and awful in the winters I've been here
in the winter okay awful but right now
it's amazing and women hate bras
like never especially in that
neighborhood East Village you're not
allowed to have one on yeah it's like
something happened I love the whole I
don't know I think it's that bra anyway
I don't know why you like the
neighborhood yeah it's actually
distracting like sometimes I get mad and
I'll say I'll go Jesus Christ you know
when you walk away trying to focus God
damn it there's an anger isn't there
yeah because you can't do anything I'm
trying to focus on my day trades here
[__] killing me it's a big yes so
anyway they hate bro that's why that bra
burning was like such a bad stupid
protest remember the women burn their
bras like Vietnam War you mean yeah they
it was like the late 60s yeah it was
like don't we're not sex objects yeah
for like treat us as sex objects I think
so yeah we're gonna have our tits
flopping all over the place you get sex
off the brains it was a bad cold ass
whatever
you worlds want to do
uh
uh well you put potato chips on a
sandwich
I would do that okay but do you do don't
okay what do you eat uh what are you
eating at the apartment are you ordering
any you're cooking what are you doing I
don't cook much at all I will go out I
have my spots I have my breakfast spots
and my breakfast sandwiches it does have
avocado on it which I think you should
write down I think that's a classy thing
how do you spell that um is it just from
the corner are you going to like a
little bit fancier of a spot
I got one fancy spot that I sort of
saved for like when I'm feeling like I
really deserve it and then I have a
trashier place which is still good but
it's a fake egg I know they're just
opening some egg and something every
morning you're getting breakfast out
every morning this morning I did a
smoothie I'll do that sometimes too okay
I found my smoothie spot and I get my
spots and I love my spots and at night
I'll probably have like there's a few
good restaurants and then there's like a
truck where I do this I do go to a truck
food truck okay a couple times a week is
there anything in the house food wise uh
apple and peanut butter is like my snack
really yeah it's a good sick every now
and then I'll put some like they have
these Trader Joe's things that are like
cauliflower chips and I'll do hummus and
that it's like a snack so you eat pretty
good uh you're trying to keep it tight I
try to keep that I also try to not eat
after like seven or eight pm
I don't I want to eat so bad but I know
it's just like you know beating that
hole and it's so nice and short and just
like shove food in your face preaching
to the choir kid yeah I cheat a lot but
okay what's the uh the Boudoir like the
bedroom you got a king-sized bed no it's
a queen I'm renting from a friend of a
friend okay tiny tiny place but I'm
looking at apartments but it's so
expensive I can't believe like what you
get for the money I mean yeah a box in
that area it's nuts so it was already
4.5 million dollars for like a small and
then they're like age if he's three
thousand dollars that's wild who bought
who can
look if you have 10 million dollars
maybe you're gonna buy like a well like
a two million dollar place like if you
if you have 10 million dollars you're
gonna live in a little box like I have
10 million dollars yeah I don't know who
these are for but I'm I'm gonna probably
rent for a little while and then
see I don't want to get a house outside
the city because
part of why I'm leaving in La is I was
lonely in my house it's like alone you
want to be in the mix I like being in
the mix
um if I had a girlfriend I would be okay
with getting a house but just like the
idea of being in a house alone was just
like I don't know I don't like it's like
a lonely thing sure okay if I cry that'd
be good for Ratings that'd be a clip
like a good reel you know what I mean
sure
grown man cries we had a great time with
Kyle Dunnigan everybody he got sad
halfway through
uh-huh so wait hold on so the apartment
was furnished when you moved in you got
it as is okay 20 2700 a month if you eat
any of your uh take out me any of your
outside meals do you bring them into the
house to eat yeah you do do you eat it I
got a table where you sit in front of
the camera because the couch is
unbelievable I don't know how this couch
got made or sit on the floor yeah
because the couch it's like it's the
material is sandpaper if you just you
could like Smooth out take the finish
off something yeah and then they're like
three bubble seats so the huge crevices
you can't lay I don't know I don't know
why this counts is it fancy is it like a
like maybe maybe it's like I don't know
what looks good to the eye maybe it
looks good or something but it's no it's
awful it's awful you sit on the floor
and eat at the coffee table Yeah and the
yeah the coffee table was like on its
side so that's probably on its side side
wait why is it on its side uh I guess it
makes it a long ways it came like that I
just noticed it was like things on the
side that they're supposed to be stood
upright it's like a rectangle Jesus you
watch TV when you're eating yeah I've
been watching Yellow Jackets you've seen
that show I have not it's really good
okay actually dialogue is bad a lot of
the time okay almost like they're like
let's just put this in for now and later
we'll go back and make it but the story
and the structure of it and the premise
really these girls get their soccer team
they get in a plane crash you know about
those no get a plane crash and they're
stuck always a plane crash with this guy
yeah yeah that's the thing that's weird
dude that's an ongoing theme this guy's
a loose cannon well you know what my you
know YouTube sends you videos you like
and it's like a lot of playing cards
yeah of course in fact it's falling down
that's not bad I know every plane crash
they actually did a special on the one
that my dad and it was a lawyer for they
um break down and they get the black box
recorder there's actually this group
they're really sick I actually don't
recommend them because they're up
setting but they do the whole dialogue
of the black box and they reenact it you
know Jesus and it's so funny because
people actually talk really poorly you
would never write this they'll be like
they'll switch topics midsense how
people talk yeah yeah you never would it
would never make it yeah yeah but
they're like hey did we take the oh oh
man you ever have five gums like that
you're like what but that's exactly the
thing and
um God there's like the last thing
people say is so dark but fascinating
I have a theory about it too play it
honest well they'll say like we've
already crossed over into crazy world
I feel like there are no lights in your
apartment yeah no the crazy the scariest
thing that you've said is the the apples
and peanut butter is the only thing in
your apartment that's freaking me out
the most now why would that be that
seems like a very apple fiber nice
peanut butter he's got a thing with
fruit yeah
that was a fat joke okay
who's cutting the hair
uh Chinese guy okay oh yes I know if you
go to somebody yeah I mean this Chinese
guy like he's looks at every freaking
hair like he's like a punk goes right
down it you could tell trims it up real
nice okay I'm never going to anyone else
after I went to this guy I know I
normally like a girl yeah because then
it's like I think they wash your hair
and stuff it's kind of nice oh they do
no when you get a lady it's nice so
you're going to a regular Barber Shop
not a salon
okay but I'd rather lady but this guy's
good he's good yeah huh when I want a
guy rubbing my head and me feeling good
what's he charge a haircut for
it was like 60 bucks six yeah it was
good what do you think I gave him uh I
give him a couple of bucks so he did
yeah we were pushing 65 by the time
uh yeah so are you a big Tipper I am
actually a pretty good Tipper and I do
the like today I go to Best Buys this
store sucks by the way Best Buy
oh yeah
I I forgot I leave things I I'm a
forgetful whatever and uh human being
and I left my charger my mom's house I
had to go buy another charger for my
laptop you know so I go to Best Buy and
then I get the charger and I'm like is
this the right one I have this kind of
computer like yeah that's the one I take
it home unpackage it which is like a
nightmare on packaging these things and
I'm like oh this is the wrong one let me
pack this back up and I'm like I gotta
do are you garbage so I'm stressed a
little bit you know I don't want you
guys to wait for me sure okay so I go
back to Best Buy and uh I'm just waiting
there's like there's more people working
at Best Buy than there are in the store
and I still can't get any help sure like
anybody I need this so they finally I
was probably there for 25 minutes and I
finally get the thing what am I why am I
talking about this what was the question
I'm not sure to be honest with you wait
a minute come on we can do this we gotta
go back why am I talking about this I
asked if you were a good Tipper yes okay
yeah now we're in Best Buy yeah well you
shouldn't be dipping I don't know I'm a
good Tipper but you shouldn't be dipping
in Best Buy no this is this is a great
story so the first one I buy they flip
they flip the screen so I kidnap one of
the stock guys
so they flip the screen they go you want
to give a dollar to a kid who's dying or
whatever sure and I give them a dollar
right okay yeah like a mensch I go home
I get it's the wrong one I go back I get
the new one flip the screen
by the way that Apple I got so high one
night I don't do a lot of drugs but I
got so hot and we get really high and
then you go I don't want to get any more
High yeah get that and then it goes
and you get even more high so that's
what happened I was like oh no my friend
was with me we're kind of walking
through Best Buy and then I go into the
you know they have like Best Buy and you
go in there and there's like an Apple
store it's like
you know they have an Apple store in the
middle of Best Buy I didn't no insane
they make oh do you know about it oh
yeah yeah they in the middle of a bet
you'll notice now they make a full Apple
Store okay all with all the products on
the exact same everything display
everything so I'm very really high and
I'm just in the Apple Store area and I'm
so high I forget I ever was in Best Buy
now I I'm sure I'm in the Apple Store I
take two steps to my left
and they had exploded I wasn't at Best
Buy and I was like why is this happening
wait a minute I'm in a new dimension I
couldn't
understand you're in vacuum cleaner
section yeah what is it yeah
anyway that's my Best Buy chunk of my
stand-up size so you do tip guns
I did I tip I don't go I don't go top I
go middle though and then go give you
the other screen 20 25 30. okay I don't
know 30. I'm not a you know if you went
to a family wedding like one of the
younger generation was getting married
what kind of cash are you putting in the
envelope
I got nieces okay
[Music]
I give all my these nephews 100 bucks
for their birthdays okay
cash hundred bucks I gotta pay taxes I'm
really giving them 140.
you'll stop those prick you know what
that's costing me on a back end it's one
point right actually with LA I'm paying
50 taxes you know taxes really
like I'm in right in the area where they
they screw the most they get you like if
you're really poor you actually don't
pay much taxes or if you're really rich
you can get away with them the mill yeah
squeeze you
uh in a wedding uh my niece gets wedding
if
you're taking a date too it's you on a
date so you gotta covered her the odds
of me taking their low okay okay I'm
sorry very strange person today
[Laughter]
what are we doing
guys come to the safe space
uh five thousand dollars maybe shut up
what it's like for a wedding yeah five
grand a thousand I I actually don't know
what you're supposed to get what are you
supposed to get I would give what you're
supposed to get maybe a little extra
what have you give have you given what
have I guess for sure
oh for like a family like no one I know
that this is the first time like a niece
got married okay Mary so I wouldn't know
is even on the high end okay 500. okay
is there a wedding coming up where this
is about to happen no but when you're
saying when one of them get married
you're thinking between a grand and five
grand to give well not now
it just saved 45. oh yeah
I should have been like that's it I
would have asked beforehand like what's
normal and then I would have uh I think
the rule of thumb is you try to cover
what the cost of you and your date is
which is he's got cash we talking about
day trading I'm just kidding I don't do
a lot of day every night I don't do a
lot of daytime long term okay he's in it
all Warren Buffett a grand would be ours
that's a lot that's crazy that's a big a
big gift is a green five grand man you
are all over the place how much cash you
got on you right now
uh Cash Cash yeah like the actual
scratch
not liquid assets like what do you have
do I know my liquid assets now uh I got
uh I got a baggie of of five grand at my
apartment so don't tell people that
don't know where I live you gave down
your address listen that's because I do
stand up and I put if you put the cash
in a baggie we're gonna have to bleach
come on they don't know where I live
listen you literally gave the
intersection
we're gonna go to Every break in every
apartment so we'd be waiting with a
second nickels to take you out
of [__] it I got weapons
the baggie is the best
it's a flashlight no it's not a
flashlight it is a flashlight but it's
the flashlight oh yeah flashlight that
puts in you like blind you no but yeah
it blinds you or it should blind your
ass
everything's all right take my apples
I gotta go I feel like I've said too
much yeah you're [__] perfect you're
perfect are you wearing cologne no no
well my my deodorant some people think
I'm wearing cologne sometimes it's my
deodorant what do you like to use I go
Old Spice gentlemen very nice deodorant
antiperspirant or deodorant honestly I
don't know I don't know okay
I try to get this stuff I think um Old
Spice doesn't have the aluminum who
knows what the [__] you have here but
they're like don't have aluminum ones
okay do you own any binoculars
I do but they were a gift for my dad
okay and then like you know I don't know
if you know he died you've mentioned it
yeah I did yeah
um so I just took those but I don't use
them I mean okay
but now that you mention it
good idea yeah they're in California
they're in a box I gotta ship all that
do you cross your sevens no no no no no
that is very is that a fancy thing to do
or a trash thing it's fancy yeah
do you ask the same questions everybody
there's a lot well
yeah pull from a pool of a couple
hundred problems this is a good idea for
a podcast I gotta think of an idea like
this thanks buddy yeah and then when you
come on up on a handgun
are you a boozer no no I do like the
feeling of being drunk but I I get sick
pretty quick it's like a bad okay I feel
bad and I also break out in um yeah so
you don't drink at all no I I like a
little like glass of wine with my
Italian uh the pasta
or anything you know
uh but
um but I um
don't drink sometimes on a date you know
you want to just drink a little bit to
loosen up
but not really much are you doing much
dating yeah I've been I've been trying
to do that a lot more in the city mm-hmm
and it's going good I'm actually trying
to talk to people in public they never
asked a girl out that I didn't know okay
one time I did which was a disaster but
I I think that's a good better way to
meet than a an app to like chat but it's
so uncomfortable to chat someone up sure
but it's kind of fun she just walked up
to some girl you didn't know hey how are
you I'm Kyle I didn't do that but like
the other day I was like in line at the
bathroom and those and those were
waiting and it was a both gender
whatever like whatever was in your pants
you can all use the same bathroom is
that a restaurant yeah it's like take
out your dick and balls your vagina and
every room is fine for you
and so I'm like hey this isn't I just
started chatting up like this isn't good
for guys you know you women are in there
all the the whole [__] time sure
yeah I didn't say I I said it like much
more Charming I was like what do you
thinking and boy she she liked me a lot
but she really showed it by leaving and
not talking to me much but playing hard
to get I'm I'm this I'm I'm working up
and I'm baby stepping trying to talk to
people but I have to do the apps you do
the apps now when you take a lady out to
dinner are you paying oh yeah nice I pay
yeah I always pay okay and um it's funny
because sometimes it I expect someone to
thank me but sometimes they don't thank
you that's really weird that would
bother me too I had a girl once I was
like yeah what is our place actually I
want to try this place down the street
from my house it was the most expensive
restaurant in Los Angeles
I think it was called like expensive
ease and she was like this this or it
was we sat there for oh almost two hours
and hour one in I go oh she's asked me
zero questions about me zero to the
point where she goes I love Portland and
I go I was in Portland last weekend
waiting for her to go where'd you go
what'd you do anything nothing I would
lay up these things and have awkward
silence that you should tell me me again
anyway that was four hundred dollars
yeah but yeah dating is expensive for
sure here in New York City uh let's go
into the bathroom
your bathroom at your house are you
peeing in the shower
no every now and then emergency wise but
it's not like
a regular thing no pressure in there
no
that sounds insane now that sounds
insane you just had a taser out of them
I draw the line at toothpaste in a tub
okay sir okay
uh what are you sleeping in
uh boxers boxer your boxer man yeah yeah
so you put your socks on
at the start and then I wake up and
they're gone like a magic fairy took
them off
I never remember taking them off but
they're always gone
so jury's out on what's doing that how
many pillows are you using when you
sleep one on the head one between the
knees because my knees are very knobbing
and nice I like that so you sleep on
your side I mostly side you're not
hugging are you hugging one when I'm a
little sad
most mates every now and then I do come
up top like a lady I'll grab her like a
lady
you keep a fan on you while you're
sleeping yeah well this place there's no
AC in the bedroom it's in the main room
it's a small place so the main room it
does get in there with a little fans
it's fun yeah is there a window in the
bedroom yeah yeah
it's it's good no AC
what do you think it's cool in there I
mean ah can you play acoustic guitar I
play a lot of instruments actually yes
I'm like I very much uh play music a lot
and write songs okay yes a piano piano
May is my main thing yeah what age did
you start like 12 we had a piano in our
basement but half the keys were broken
but it was good because I would bang on
it you know just for hours on end I just
pee myself but my parents but it was
good to learn because I had to like in
my head imagine what the notes were so
now I can write more and I can like uh
can you read music I can't read music
but I can hear it and and play like I
could figure out songs that way no [__]
wrote yeah Billy Joel a lot of like how
I learned okay I wanted to learn that
song so I'd figure the the song out sure
that's pretty classy I'll give you the
battery would you ever play acoustic
guitar at a party like if there was if
you were to like a house party in La
would you like grab the guitar
[Music]
like this is a good joke stuff I was
like hey I have this song about yeah you
know we're having you're doing a goof
yeah all right yeah
yeah huh Mr Dunnigan all right give it
to me I feel good I feel you did pretty
well
is that is that right
good 100 class my friend yeah uh no no
yeah you're uh you're trash baby trash
give me a little more detail like why is
that I've had that that plane we have if
you want to see here should we go over
well I mean what is what is really tip
what are the top three things where
you're like this is this is true taser
wasn't great taser uh that was a that
was an error to bring that out
on the floor is in classy but what about
the couch it's a forest
I give you that do I get a rebuttal or
is it just yeah okay of course I feel
like that the taser yes I'm giving you
that thank you okay
I used it brandish a weapon on a comedy
and I fired it without you telling you
what about when you fly will you bring
food on the airplane
uh I usually buy food there if I'm got
some leftovers I might put in but I
don't pack a plain lunch no that'd be
crazy will you put your seat back on a
plane the seat back yeah where you put
the seat back so you can lay down you
know sit back oh yeah yeah you do that
who doesn't a lot of people you take
your shoes off on the plane yeah long
flight yeah okay I have a really bad
foot though and New York is killing me
I'm trying to ignore that I need surgery
I just keep walking on it what's wrong
with the foot everything my father when
I you know my father who never complains
that he died yes my dad died oh my God
yeah he never complained and he always
he would say to me take care of your
feet I was like what the [__] does that
mean but he had he had so much foot pain
he wouldn't complain but he would tell
me because he could see my fears him I
went to a foot doctor she she goes your
feet and then she kind of had no no
words like that and then she goes you
have no fat on the bottom of your feet
she was no wonder you're in pain you
have no fat and then you have a bone
spur in the heel of arch collapse and
you have arthritis and a hammer toe and
I I just don't know how you can walk but
through the power of Christ
a little prayer so anyway I found a new
way to walk okay
yeah no I got I got I'll say yeah do it
back here
but like you know I normally walk on the
Footwear but now in New York I go walk
so far I'm back here okay centered here
it's very awkward but I go that looks
normal dude
it looks like you're walking not down a
hill
I can walk mile I can walk a lot further
do they play The Pink Panther music as
you're walking
I can't I can't believe you're striking
out on the apps big guys
[Laughter]
you never thought that was weird either
I thought the Pink Panther crystallized
what I'm doing hey where you ladies
going slow down I got a hammer toe and a
taser it looks like you're walking the
wrong way on a moving sidewalk
I'm glad my chronic pain is a source of
laughter
so things like
it's like this in that direction
um like why are we pleading our case
then
he's the son of a lawyer he turned it
around on us heard this whole court
system upside down that's not that's not
admissible
man the Billy Joel thing obviously yeah
I forgot about that you rushed the stage
and told him you had AIDS I didn't tell
my dads I in my head in my head but that
I mean 18 year old kid as a kid like
Billy Joel
you know needed some attention all right
I'll take it I'll tell you what are most
people garbage yeah yeah most everybody
okay so it's not like we had a garbage
guy in two years
[Music]
we need this for Ratings or otherwise
it's not gonna work podcast makes no
sense
one of the funniest man oh man Kyle
Dunnigan yeah such a good absolutely
fine hysterical buddy had nothing to do
today thank you guys nice meeting you
guys it's you guys are fun you had Best
Buy what are you talking about yeah I
did yeah yeah did you get the right one
by the way yeah it was only 150 for the
charger for my
laptop okay that's crazy you have an
Apple laptop yeah it's pretty good yeah
I yeah it's not gonna pull you out of
this but it's still pretty sweet it's on
the it's on the like not you know trashy
size no not at all I don't feel like you
I don't know I don't think you measured
everything and waited I think we got
enough I think we really we hit a lot of
data points you Cherry Picked a little
bit you offered these stories I grew up
in Connecticut that was brushed over
like no big deal
but you said it was the poor part
yeah hey man a lot of people turn their
back on their upbringing man yeah
the poor part of Malibu is
which
thinks that we don't know that would
make you classy they haven't told us so
nice about you like hey you can hang
your hat on like hey I really do this I
do that do you own a suit do you know
how to tie a tie How many pairs of dress
shoes do you own are they Orthopedic
what kind of credit cards are you
throwing around you got an AMX card yeah
go old gold Amex yeah that's pretty good
that's all right yeah that ain't bad
it's really good who'd you steal that
from
do you have a Discover card no okay all
right that's good
um God is there anything
I drive a really like a really classic
car what do you got Tesla okay and it's
class yeah we own stock in it you're
just trying to juice the numbers well
I'd say you know if um you don't have
that out here right that's out it's
getting shipped right now
you guys see it as it's being shipped
because these cameras you can you're
having the car shipped from California
now that's pretty classy
what'd that cost you no don't give them
that
uh like 1500. all right it was like a
wedding gift price
wait what
I said at a wedding you should give a
thousand dollars that's true yeah yeah
it's callbacks what's going on I thought
that somebody gave that he has a wedding
gift I'm like you're not married
I thought you just lied and said I got
Matt you're looking for a deal you could
see the uh the cameras you could see
what's going on sometimes it's traveling
sometimes it's like parked yes he's
parked there holy Toyota wait hold on is
someone driving it yeah they got it
they're gonna put it on one of these
cars or something whoa that's pretty
crazy you can access that when you're
not yeah Teslas are amazing so the car's
on right now yeah
uh no it's not on like no it's not
burning batteries they're turning the
lights on yeah it's like you could you
could lock the doors open the window you
can do stuff from the app of a thing so
you could freak out the guy that's
driving that yes just turn it yeah you
can honk the horns I'm gonna honk the
horn right now
let's honk the horn
people I I this is not me trying to pump
the stock but like people are just
pumping dumps
give Tesla the ayg bump but they're done
again [__] makes off to the Caribbean
with all his cash on a private plane
well you know there's a lot of
misinformation about electric vehicles
because they're trying to there's a lot
of money trying to squelch it and so I I
feel like talking about it because
they're so awesome they're so they
equate going to the game they're trying
to take down Big Oil this is this
episode's brought to you by Exxon this
week no I know maybe I shouldn't talk
about it
but I mean you never people think they
they equate going to the gas station is
charging station but you never go to the
charging station you charge it at your
house like would you ever buy a phone
where to go out and and fill it up sure
like you never it's always fully charged
you got to charge her at the house yeah
that's a couple two three bucks it's two
or three bucks but you if you live in a
condo you can plug into a regular outlet
it'll still charge okay you know can we
ask what the house is on the market for
ballpark
uh uh 1.9 million okay let's see how we
got it yeah we'll see if we get it I
mean it's the Market's like crashing
right now sure where do you go on
vacations now I don't vacation you don't
vacation at all my life is like a
vacation travel we do stand up right
it's like you never go anywhere for a
couple of days down the island something
like that relax I don't if I had a
girlfriend I would I would probably do
something you would do that but like I'm
going alone just being on the beach just
like
hey you hear about these bathrooms they
suck for guys
I don't take my bathroom you want to see
me honk the horn on a Tesla 2 000 miles
away
real panty dropper yeah
on the floor ah man we love you
everybody I feel like we could hang out
anything you want to folks out there to
know you had you hit him hey Kyle
dunnigan.com
I got a fall tour coming up I got a plug
Kyle Dunnigan comedy.com right here's a
Kyle Dunnigan I got Kyle Dunnigan come
Kyle Dunnigan back okay
nice yeah yeah and you got the YouTube
page yeah yeah one of the funniest
moments one of the funniest Instagram
Pages thank you forget about it yeah
everybody loves you thanks guys thank
you we can't thank you enough Kippy what
do you got for him uh we're over the
road we just added a second show at the
Fillmore in Philadelphia get those
goddamn tickets gang let's do it twice
we love you thanks for the support scoop
them up gang we love you and we'll see
you next week peace